[Musique]
bienvenue sur 974 télé dans votre
émission vivre ensemble aujourd'hui
consacré au Tage trempelin pour
l'activité des jeunes nouveau dispos
mise en place par le département avec
moi sur le plateau aujourd'hui Monsieur
C la Pressade directeur au département
madame Villard directrice de la Boutique
de Gestion et Monsieur Achard Julien
jeune bénéficiaire du Tage bienvenue à
vous merci bonjour alors Monsieur C la
Pressade expliquez-nous pourquoi le
département a lancé ce nouveau
dispositif et tout simplement parce que
vous savez qu'à la Réunion
malheureusement le contexte
socioéconomique est assez difficile
notamment pour les jeunes réunionnés il
faut savoir qu'on a plus de 20000 jeunes
réunionnés âgés de 15 à 24 ans qui sont
au chômage depuis plusieurs mois ce sont
les chifff de l'INC de 2014 ça s'est un
peu amélioré depuis quelques mois mais
véritablement les élus du conseil
départemental ont souhaité mettre en
place une action innovante puisque le
Tage va faire la promotion d'un projet
de création d'entreprise donc on parle
d'une idée de création d'une entreprise
et au fur et à mesure de par l'
accompagnement avec nos partenaires du
réseau pinchance et bien ils vont
pouvoir formaliser un projet création
d'entreprise et la notion de projet
permet de se lancer en matière de
perspective professionnelle bien entendu
et aussi de définir l'insertion
professionnelle durable dans laquelle on
souhaite s'inscrire et le Tage au
travers de cette subvention je dirais
d'aide au démarrage de la création d'
entreprise permet de soutenir des jeunes
réunionnés justement qui est concerné
par ce dispositif alors les jeunes de 20
à 30 ans puisque c'est le l'âge sur
lequel les élus du conseil départemental
ont souhaité accompagner les jeunes et
il y a une dérogation pour les jeunes de
17 ans parce que parfois on peut avoir
des situations de de jeunes on va dire
émancipés qui souhaitent s'inscrire dans
une démarche de création d'entreprise et
véritablement donc un jeune qui a qui
correspond à ces critères d'éigibilité
pourra se faire accompagner par le
département et par les structures du
réseau. chance très bien vous avez parlé
d'aide
financière en quoi consiste alors le
trempelin pour la activité des jeunes on
est sur une subvention de 8000 € au
maximum donc une subvention c'est
c'est-à-dire qu'on va pas rembourser la
somme qui sera octroyé par la
collectivité départementale cette
subvention sera versée en en deux
versements d'une part 76 % dès que le
dossier est validé par les instances du
conseil départemental et 30 % lorsque
véritablement on sera assuré que
l'activité a bien démarré et sur Rael de
fond du bénéficiaire du Tage monsieur
Achard
bonjour vous êtes tout jeune
bénéficiaire du Tage parlez-nous de
votre parcours ben mon parcours il est
simple euh moi je viens du je suis
d'originaire de la Réunion mais je suis
parti me former au Canada à l'âge de 18
ans et du coup j'ai vu pas mal de choses
là-bas dont mon projet j'ai tiré des des
idées qui viennent de là-bas et j'ai
toujours voulu revenir à la Réunion
pourir investir dans mon pays donc
voilà un peu mon
parcours donc vous avez une première
expérience de mobilité au Canada c'est
ce que vous disiez vous avez travailler
là-bas et ensuite vous êtes revenu à la
réunon et là vous avez voulu créer votre
propre entreprise voilà exactement
d'accord actuellement alors vous en êtes
où dans le montage de
votre tout avance bien ça ça s'achève et
je peux on va dire que dici ce weekend
ah je pourrais démarrer
voilà alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dévoiler un peu plus sur ce projet
ben du coup ce projet ça consiste à être
un foood truck qui est emménagé plus
dans une remorque que dans un camion par
rapport à mon budget qui était restreint
donc j'ai préféré minimiser les coûts et
investir dans une remoque qui va être
tractée par par une voiture et du coup
ben c'est ce foot trck là aura pour but
de vendre des burgers et des chich c'est
un plat libanais qui vient qui est
beaucoup populaire à Montréal au Canada
à Québec donc je ramène ça ici à la
Réunion pour vous faire découvrir ça et
tout étant dit mettre un clin d'œil
aussi pour la réunion dans au niveau des
saveur apportter au plat bon on a un
nouveau produit à tester bientôt
mesdames et messieurs madame Villard
vous êtes la marine de Monsieur Hachard
vous l'avez accompagné dans le cadre du
Plan 4000 jeunes oui effectivement j'ai
rencontré Julien il y a il y a 1 an 1 an
et demi maintenant euh dans le cadre
d'une
de de ce plan 4000 je parené la Maison
Départementale de sainte-clautine m'a
appelé euh madame GEVIA notamment m'a
appelé en me demandant de venir
rencontrer ce jeune homme qui euh qui
avait un projet de création d'entreprise
euh nous nous sommes rencontrés nous
avons fait un premier point tous les
deux et puis ensuite on a on a signé un
contrat lui la Maison départementale les
mois pour mettre en place effectivement
cet accompagnement alors à la création
d'entreprise effectivement mais cet
accompagnement du jeune comme c'était
prévu dans le cadre du du plan 4000
jeunes parés d'ailleurs j'ai cinq autres
quatre autres filleules qui ne sont pas
tous dans la création d'entreprise mais
en l'occurrence Julien était dans ce
dans ce parcours là très bien alors au
titre de la Boutique de Gestion vous
intervenez dans le processus
d'attribution du Tage alors
effectivement nous nous sommes la
Boutique de Gestion est une structure du
réseau Point chance et notre notre cœur
de métier est l'accompagnement à la
création d'entreprise pour un public en
difficulté ça veut dire que nous
travaillons avec le porteur de projet
l'étude de faisabilité tous les éléments
du marché d'abord on valide qu'il y ait
un vrai une vraie adéquation entre entre
le jeune et et son et le secteur
d'activité dans lequel il va se lancer
nous réalisons avec lui l'étude de
marché on lui indique comment faire
l'objectif est d'autonomiser le jeune le
jeune ou le moins jeune d'ailleurs enfin
d'autonomiser le porteur de projet on
fait le business plan et on mobilise les
financements nécessaires à la
réalisation du projet dont le
[Musique]
Tage c'est en conférence de presse que
le département de La Réunion et les
membres du réseau pointchance présentent
le nouveau dispositif d'insertion de la
collectivité le Tage trempelin pour
l'activité des jeunes je m'adresse en
fait à toutes les tous les jeunes de La
Réunion c'est vrai que depuis des années
on parle de jeunes au chômage de jeunes
en difficulté bon de des émeutes ou
autres et c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup
de jeunes on voit leur projets dans les
journaux bon ils ont des dons et tout et
en fait il n'y a pas de suite et ben
justement par ce projetage le projetage
tremplin donc pour l'activité des jeunes
c'est une subvention comme la présidente
a dit de 8000 € qui permettra aux jeunes
de s'initier à une entreprise bien
encadré par des réseaux point chance
dont les couus ou Boutiques de Gestion
et ça permettra aux jeunes de s'initier
à entreprise et de rentrer dans le monde
économique en créant sa propre activité
face à un taux de chômage important plus
de 60 % des jeunes réunionnés sont à la
recherche d'un emploi la collectivité
inscrit donc la jeunesse au cœur du plan
départemental d'insertion pour Stéphanie
et Jonathan le moment est symbolique au
moment de la signature de leur arrêté
notifiant leur attribution du Tage ça va
déboucher sur plein de choses autant
pour mon entreprise que moi-même
euh mon rêve se réalise comme on dit euh
et puis bon ben comme je compte
justement vu que j'ai embauché une
salariée donc en prothésie angulaire
pouvoir à ce moment-là la prendre plus
souvent selon la demande et répondre
plus facilement à la demande des
clientes les jeunes réunionnés en
difficulté social âgé de 20 à 30 ans et
souhaitant se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat pourront compter sur
ce nouveau dispositif d'insertion les
partenaires techniques du réseau Point
chance accompagneront ces jeunes dans
dans le montage des dossiers ainsi que
dans la faisabilité de leur projet on va
accompagner dans toutes ces phases de
création le porteur de projet on va le
sensibiliser à la création dans le cadre
de séances d'information à la Chambre de
commerce on va le former et on va
l'aider à monter son business plan et à
l'intérieur de ce bus de ce business
plan on va optimiser les dispositifs et
donc maintenant qu'il y a cette ce
dispositif Tage on va forcément orienter
les personnes qui sont éligibles vers ce
dispositif qui est quand même assez
facile et simple à mettre en place et le
délai n'est pas très long non plus ce
qu'on regarde principalement c'est ce
qu'on appelle adéquation homme projet
donc effectivement si on a cette
adéquation c'est un peu plus évident
pour aboutir à la créationentreprise et
lorsqu'on est face à une un parcours qui
est un peu moins évident et bien il
s'agit véritablement de se faire
accompagner en amont par des partenaires
du chance le département de La Réunion
espère soutenir 300 projets de création
d'entreprise pour cette année pour le
moment ils sont SEP à avoir bénéficié du
trempelin pour l'activité des jeunes
tous ceux qui ont des vrais projets qui
ont envie de créer leur entreprise venez
il n'y a pas de de montant euh euh euh
d'enveloppe voilà restreinte créer votre
entreprise vous pouvez même créer de
l'emploi puisque euh les les deux
premières années vous pouvez avoir un
contrat aidé à 0 € hein ce qui permettra
également à votre entreprise d'avoir
aussi la création d'emploi j'ai toujours
adoré la mode je faisais déjà des
vêtements à mes poupées puis en
grandissant j'en ai fait pour ma sœur ma
mère et finalement j'ai toujours eu ce
rêve de travail dans la mode alors comme
je ne trouvais pas de travail j'ai
décidé de réaliser mon projet grâce au
trempelin pour l'activité des jeunes et
j'ai enclenché ma motivation avec
l'accompagnement du département j'ai pu
lancer mon atelier de couture alors vous
aussi réalisez vos rêves avec le
tremplin pour l'activité des jeunes avec
le département enclenche ta motivation
déclenche ta vie appelle le numéro vert
au 0801801
[Musique]
00 on va parler un peu du suivi post
création qui est également très
important comment vous intervenez auprès
des jeunes entrepreneurs alors
effectivement on intervient en amont de
la création pour mettre en place un
business plan pour essayer de déterminer
comment va se passer l'entreprise et
puis quand le jeune est créé et bien il
se il se trouve confronté à un certain
nombre de d'informations de données qui
sont pas toujours évidentes à à
enregistrer à gérer à traiter c'est donc
il y a un suiv postcréation qui va se
dérouler sur de ou 3 ans durant lequel
on va d'une part accompagner le jeûne
dans toutes les obligation légales
administrativ et cetera mais également
en ayant pour objectif très très clair
de l'autonomiser le responsabiliser dans
son projet de création dans sa création
et sa gestion d'entreprise monsieurchard
n'hésitez pas à profiter de ça de cette
accompagnement de la Boutique de Gestion
je bien y profiter t'inquiétez pas alors
Monsieur C la PR d'autres dispositifs
existe sont-ils cumulables avec le Tage
effectivement il y a d'autres
dispositifs il y a la subvention qui est
octroyée par l'État qui s'appelle le
pige le projet initiative jeune qui a
connu depuis quelques temps un montant
qui a été revu à la baisse he puisquon
initialement était de l'ordre de plus de
7320 € je crois de mémoire aujourd'hui
est cont tenu B des contraintes
budgétaires de l'État et et un montant
beaucoup moindre pour les jeunes rinonné
et donc le Tage de 8000 € peut se
cumuler avec cette dide de de sous forme
de subvention de l'État mais au-delà de
de cumule subvention on a également
l'opportunité de mobiliser soit des
prêts d'honneur comme c'est le cas avec
l'association initiative r entreprend ou
mieux encore puisque c'est important de
ce qu'on appelle l'intermédiation
bancaire c'estd la possibilité de faire
intervenir une banque dans le plan de
financement on parle de business plan et
c'est important que à un moment donné un
banquier fasse confiance à un jeune
réunionné qui joue je dis pas sa vie
mais qui à un moment donné présente un
projet de vie pour pouvoir s'insérer
durablement et avoir le concours d'une
banque parce que la banque sera
important pour ouvrir un compte
professionnel pour l'accompagner dans je
dirais la mise en œuvre d'un trésorerie
et donc véritablement le tâ c'est un un
coup de pouce pour pouvoir justement
mobiliser d'autres financements publics
mais également d'avoir cette opportunité
de dire qu'on a des fonds propres via ce
dispositif misise en place par le
Conseil départemental madame Villard
vous vouliez intervenir sur ce point oui
tout à fait don quand Monsieur T Prade
parlait de de financement bancaire
effectivement on peut cumuler notamment
avec le dispositif NACRE ou qui est une
partie prédonneur et une partie
prébancaire pour accompagner les jeunes
dans dans leur plan de financement dans
la réalisation de leur plan de
financement très bien monsieur Achard la
création d'entreprise c'est un vrai
challenge est-ce que vous vous seriez
lancé dans la création d'entreprise sans
l'aide du Tage ben sans l' du Tage ça
aurait été vraiment difficile je pense
que je pas lancé tout de suite en tout
cas mais c'est sûr que avec le tâ ça me
donne vraiment un gros coup de main et
l'encouragement parce que voilà le le
projet est viable on croit au projet
aussi donc c'est ça qui qui est bien
d'encourager les jeunes parce que c'est
les jeunes qui amènent de la nouveauté
pour la Réunion quoi alors profitons de
l'émission pour leur lancer un petit
message ben en tout cas tous les jeunes
que je vois ben lâchez pas baissez pas
les bras puis tapeer sur les portes faut
faut faut faut comme dirait l'expression
faut défoncer les portes donc
allez-y madame Villard la création
d'entreprise est une des voix
d'insertion professionnelle pour nos
publics en difficulté qu'en est-il pour
les jeunes ben effectivement c'est une
une vraie façon d'avoir une première
expérience d'avoir un premier emploi on
sait que trouver un emploi c'est
difficile encore plus quand on est jeune
et les jeunes débordent de d'idées
nouvelles on le voit avec Julien avec ce
food truck parce que il a vu quelque
chose un petit peu d'innovant d'un petit
peu original
s dit pourquoi pas le mettre en place
les jeunes ont ont ont de par leur âge
cette cette espèce de de de droit à
l'expérimentation on a des jeunes qui
seront créateurs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui qui peut-être ne le seront
pas demain qui continueront peut-être à
l'être mais en tout cas il y a ce droit
à à l'expérimentation pour cette
première année de lancement combien de
tages visez-vous on a lancé le
dispositif depuis janvier 2016 donc
c'est tout récent à l'échelle du
département et véritablement on a
actuellement vraiment beaucoup de
dossiers parce que par que nos
partenaires sur le terrain dont la beuté
de gestion sont ceux qui sont les plus
grands prescripteurs de ces dossiers on
a actuellement une cinquantaine de
dossiers reçu plus d'une 25 dossiers ont
été déjà validés par les instances du
conseil départemental il y a d'autres
qui sont en cours parce que il y a pas
très longtemps encore on était en
commission technique pour pouvoir
valider les dossiers notre objectif au
niveau des services c'est vraiment une
réactivité parce que Monsieur hacha a
évoquer un projet il s'agit pour lui d'
une réponse je dirais dans dans le mois
un mois et demi auou plus tard pour
commencer son activité et ensuite bien
sûr avoir les premiers versements donc
euh on est dans une dynamique où on
souhaite accompagner le maximum de
projets portés par des jeunes réunionnés
bien entendu l' par rapport aux critères
que j'aiévoqué précédemment et donc euh
le dispositif prend son envol très bien
monsieur CIT la présade vous qu'est-ce
que vous souhaitez dire aux jeunes de La
Réunion comme l'a dit Madame Villard la
création d'entreprise à la Réunion c'est
une voie d'insertion professionnelle
durable on a plus de 5000 créations
entreprise qui se monent chaque année
notamment
50 % on pourra dire de personnes qui
sohaitent créer leur propre emploi as la
création d'une entreprise pourquoi pas
un jeune et un jeune peut-être
effectivement a besoin pe ce droit à
l'expérimentation et il a le droit
d'être accompagné par les pouvoirs
publics donc le Conseil départemental
mais également par nos partenaires comme
le réseau Point chance la boutille de
gestion qui sont financés cofinancés par
le département avec des fonds européens
pour apporter un service public de
qualité et un service efficace puisque
lorsque on crée une entreprise ça peut
prendre plusieurs mois et l'objectif
c'est que la personne puisse être
autonome et responsable dans la gestion
quotidien de peti
[Musique]
entreprise avec Tom on a toujours été
amis depuis qu'on est petit on a fait
les caps en coup et surtout on a
toujours fait les piqueniques du
dimanche ensemble comme on souhaitait
travailler ensemble on a décidé de
monter notre affaire alors quand on a vu
qu'avec le tremplin pour l'activité des
jeunes c'était possible de le faire on a
enclenché notre motivation on a monté
notre dossier il a été accepté et avec
l'accompagnement du département on a
finalement pu lancer notre snack alors
vous aussi réalisez vos rêves avec le
trempelin pour l'activité des jeunes
avec le département enclenche ta
motivation déclenche ta vie appelle le
numéro vert au
080180100 voilà vous savez tout
maintenant sur le Tage trempelin pour
l'activité des jeunes nouveau dispositif
lancé par le Département je remercie nos
invités et je vous donne rendez-vous
dans une prochaine émission
vivre ensemble sur 974
[Musique]
télé